the jackass crew have been called The
Elder Statesman of self-inflicted harm
but time catches up with all of us so
now that Johnny Knoxville in company of
reached middle age is a fifth Jackass
movie even physically possible for them
back in the '90s Johnny noxville wasn't
yet the star we know today much like one
of his influences writer Hunter S
Thompson Knoxville was up for anything
and everything including testing
self-defense equipment on himself for
Big Brother magazine his risk-taking
didn't go unnoticed and before long the
magazine was gaining a attention from
other like-minded Daredevils including
steo soon enough the likes of Chris
Pontius and Jason wean Akuna came on
board bolstered by behind the-scenes
staff such as Jeff train and Spike Johns
this ragtag team made quirky videos for
the early internet and it didn't take
too long before people took notice with
the prospect of branching out into a
television show a few more talents were
added to the ranks including skater Bama
jera and his buddy Ryan Dunn this proved
to be the final ingredient and following
some Network shopping the crw signed up
with MTV jackass made his television
debut in April 2000 and was a near
overnight success in no time at all
nville went from doing random
commercials to make's meet to posing for
the cover of Rolling Stone the show's
success saw them break out into the big
screen in 2002 with Jackass the movie
three more movies would follow including
2022 is jackass forever following the
bugs off his success of 2010's Jackass
3D the franchise was fairly dormant for
most of the 2010s the idea of a fourth
film never quite went away though with
many fans still craving more sadly in
2011 cast member Ryan Dum was killed in
a car crash at the age of 34 this was a
tremendous loss for the crew and his
death was especially hard on bam maera
who had already been struggling with
substance abuse issues prior to dun's
passing is that right is that right
maera substance issues returned during
the production of Jackass forever as
Paramount Pictures was hesitant to allow
him to appear in the film these fears
were later substantiated when they
became a source of conflict between
majera and the film's producers
including Jeff Tain Spike Johns and
Johnny Knoxville majera even went as far
as to publicly rant about his treatment
on Instagram alleging he was being
treated like an animal by the studio he
also threatened his former friends
resulting in train slapping majera with
a restraining order this resulted in
miara being fired from Jackass forever
and aside from one stunt and a handful
of background appearances he was removed
from the film
entirely aside from the very public
breakup with B mjera another issue the
jackass forever crew had to overcome was
a CO 19 pandemic which had put Hollywood
on an indefinite pause While most
Productions simply pumped the brakes
until they were allowed to resume the
jackass crew were given some leeway by
Paramount the studio used the film as an
excuse to see what future Productions
could achieve during the pandemic this
was confirmed by wean during an
interview on the nine club with Chris
Roberts where he also explained other
ways of pandemic affected production it
seems that the team wanted to film stuff
on location in some exotic locals
however due to travel restrictions and
the varying nature of Co 19 testing in
different countries has had to be
scrapped with the arrival of various
vaccines things regarding Co 19 have
become much more manageable than they
were at the pandemic's peak so with that
hurdle removed it'll likely be much
easier to film a potential fifth
theatrical film should they decide to
pursue it jackass forever really did
feel like a Changing of the Guard for
the series especially when it came to
the cast While most of the original cast
was back for another round this entry
also introduced some new blood
predominantly because many of the
original crew couldn't push themselves
as hard as they used to the new cast
featured sha poopy's mcer Zack Holmes
Jasper Dolphin Eric monaka and Rachel
wolson this means that jackass forever
saw not only its first black cast
members but its first female cast member
as well change is never easy for any
long running franchise but in this
instance the new additions didn't feel
forced or or reductive in any way none
of them felt out of place and even
allowed for some fresh reactions to
things that perhaps the old cast might
have been desensitized to Jackass has
always been a series built off of
youthful vigor so this development makes
absolute sense and could see the
franchise continuing even when the ogs
are no longer part of the crew when it
comes to the cast of Jackass you'd be
hard pressed to find a member more
dedicated than steo from swimming with
sharks to bungee jumping and an
excrement loaded pter putty steo is the
jackass cruise into ensable man however
that doesn't mean it's always been
peaches and cream for steo both the
third and fourth films were especially
hard for the self-proclaimed Wild Boy
for different reasons Jackass 3D was
sto's first production after achieving
his sobriety something the crew all
helped him with despite his lifestyle
transition steo was still as gung-ho as
ever when it came to jackass forever
though steo said in an interview with
Entertainment Weekly that it was kind of
a bummer he went on to explain that this
attitude stemms from seeing what Johnny
Knoxville was still subjecting himself
to physically at his age he specifically
referred to a stunts that involved
Knoxville being charged into by a bull
which resulted in severe brain damage
steo told the outlet it's not fun to
watch Knoxville get hit in the head
anymore so what happened after it hit me
dud it's gnarly as a result it seems
unlikely will'll see steo or possibly
any member of the jackass crew in a
fifth feature film however we may see
them join forces for some other project
speaking with Cinema Blend in August
2023 the Daredevil explained I wouldn't
be surprised if some kind of of project
reunited us again but I wouldn't bet on
there being another movie the jackass
movies have always been a bit of an
anomaly as you wouldn't expect films of
their caliber to amass positive buzz
from the Press however with the
exception of the first film all of the
main theatrical films of positive Rotten
Tomato scores jackass forever stands as
a highest rated entry in the entire
series and it isn't hard to see why Nick
shager of Esquire described the original
cast as Elder Statesman of
self-inflicted harm which is an apt
description if we ever heard one shager
also wrote in a pandemic era of Extreme
Caution and fear it's a welcome relief
to watch Knoxville and the rest risk
life and limb for the sheer hell of it
many critics seem to share the same
sentiment with Brett do of in session
film saying I'm not going to pretend
there is some thought-provoking
underlying message that wasn't there
before but I certainly did enjoy
laughing my ass off with these friends
that ultimately might just be the appeal
of these movies a feeling of
reconnecting with something or someone
from your past with jackass forever
being both a critical and Commercial
Success many have won if Jack has 5 will
be happening sadly as of September 2023
very little has been said about a fifth
film aside from a few scans comments the
jackass films unlike other movies as
they don't have a screenplay or even a
three act narrative as opposed to a plot
the movies are more of an Eclectic
compilation of crazy stunts and pranks
of varying scales my God are you crying
I think he's hurt additionally many of
the best moments in the films aren't
even planned with several highlights
originating as something thought up on
the spot an example of this would be the
rocky prank from Jackass 3D wherein bam
majira would surprise someone with a
splash of water and a punch to the head
you can't script or coordinate
spontaneity like that and this is a key
factor in the films if a fifth Jackass
movie was announced we probably wouldn't
see a scrap of footage from it for a
very long time however when and if that
day finally comes you can rest assured
that hardcore fans of the series will be
waiting with baited breath much of the
jackass franchise's DNA stems from
Johnny Knoxville from its humble Origins
to what has become the man is
undoubtedly the series Figure Head
though it might be a head that has been
rattled by a few sizable concussions
it's still one that has helped steal the
ship since the beginning and he mentions
of a potential fifth entry have been
limited with Knoxville himself providing
the closest thing to an update in an
interview with variety Knoxville
addressed the future of the series
saying we never said whether it was or
wasn't the final film if we did continue
we would lean on the younger cast more
and the old guys would take a little
step back but still be a part of it
there may be another jackass there may
not be addressing his own part in a
possible jackass 5 Knoxville went on to
add I would have to step back because my
neurologist said I can't have any more
concussions Knoxville is the Lynch pin
of the show and even if he did have to
step back from some of the more
physically demanding stunts it still
would be great to see him play A Part
after all jackass wouldn't be the same
without Knoxville's infectious cackling
right God help me I love it throughout
the jackass series and movies we've seen
different stuns and pranks that the crew
has pulled off with acts of LW depravity
and rampant Insanity they've elicited
both hysterical laughter and visceral
discussed in equal measure we've seen
Johnny Knoxville take to the sky on a
big red rocket and steveo performed the
grossest bungee jump anyone has ever
seen most of us would flee at the mere
thought of attempting acts like this but
the jackass crew will do it with a smile
on their faces there have also been
pranks of varying scales as well
including a limousine packed with a
swarm of bees as well as a comically
giant hand to smack people needless to
say the creative juices have always been
flowing behind the scenes on jackass
with jackass forever bringing us things
such as a Shar color game involving a
bear and progo sticks in nether regions
where can they go from here with people
becoming increasingly desensitized the
crew will need to find creative ways to
up the ante with the prospect of a fifth
jackass film not disappearing anytime
soon we need to consider who would be
returning for another round or perhaps
in less of a Hands-On roll Johnny
Knoxville would likely return as the
maniacal leader spearheading the whole
thing long serving cast members
including wean steo and Chris Pontius
have also appeared in all of the
theatrical releases so far so it is
hoped they would also sign up for more
madness there is also the ever loyal
Supporting Cast of Dave England Preston
Lacy and danger Aaron three men who have
never had issues going above the Call of
Duty from being used as human football
goals to playing beehive table they've
always thrown themselves head first into
whatever was needed however as jackass
forever showed us the old guard seems to
be passing the torch to a new generation
of untrained stump performers these
Fresh Faces each have a clear love for
the series many of them having grown up
with their in the early 2000s it seems
that as long as there are people bold
enough to push themselves to the very
limit then the spirit of Jackass will
never die whether for a fifth film or
for another series it remains to be seen
whether we will see more from our
favorite pranksters or
not